joining us is dr amish adalja he's a
senior scholar at the johns hopkins
center for health security at the
bloomberg school of public health
and he's in pittsburgh dr adalja thanks
for joining us
so let's talk about those new cdc
guidelines for camp
specifically camps that where everyone
has been
vaccinated can go at full capacity and
massless however
it's a bit more complicated when it
comes to camps
where not everyone has gotten a shot are
these some of the challenges that will
be facing
our schools come september
i definitely think that when you have a
population that is partly vaccinated
another part is not vaccinated it's
going to be
challenging to be able to separate those
people out and come up with different
policies
but i think policy has to really reflect
the fact that these vaccines are
extremely effective
that they reduce your ability to get to
contract this infection they make you no
longer a threat and i think the guidance
has to reflect the fact that
if you're fully vaccinated this is
basically kind of the pre-pandemic life
for you
and when you're unvaccinated that there
are still going to be some areas that
are high risk and you might have to take
some different measures
you mentioned the pre-pandemic life and
i'm thinking about travel this weekend
we're talking about expecting to see
a huge number of travelers because so
many are vaccinated previously
christmas time thanksgiving we saw a
surge in cases after travel
like this will it be different because
of those vaccinations this time around
i definitely believe that when you have
a vaccinated population 40 percent of
the us population is fully vaccinated
that makes it harder for this virus to
spread and you also have people with
natural immunity
there are going to likely be
unvaccinated people that gather we may
see cases but
what the goal of this vaccine was was to
decouple cases from
severe disease hospitalization and death
and because 75 percent of our seniors
are
fully vaccinated we're not going to see
cases translate into hospitals in crisis
again like we did
during thanksgiving during christmas
during other gatherings because so many
of the high-risk people have been
vaccinated so we may see some uptick in
cases in those unvaccinated people but
we're going to have to start moving away
from looking at cases because we're not
going to get to zero
what we're trying to do is make this
more like a tame respiratory virus that
we deal with year in and year out and i
think we're on that trajectory
as we get more people vaccinated doctor
lots of as you know lots of renewed
discussion this week about whether covid
was naturally occurring
or originated in a lab what what do you
make of what you think we're going to
find from the covert 19 origins report
and will we ever actually get an
answer as to where it came from it's
going to be challenging to figure out
what happened in those early
days we know that the wuhan institute of
virology was working with
coronaviruses we know that they've
failed to be transparent we know that
we're seeing
some contradictory messaging coming from
there but i think the important thing to
do is try and
get access to the medical records of
those people that work there those three
individuals who were hospitalized in
november
trying to understand what viruses they
were working with there because
there are other coronaviruses we're
going to face and we need to understand
how
these viruses emerge from bats into some
intermediate animal or if this came
if this was an accident in the lab we
need to know that we also need to
improve biosafety at labs
if it is something where there are
lapses that occur because this isn't
going to be the first time that we deal
with
dangerous infectious diseases and i
think it's really important that we get
to this and it's really important for
the chinese government to be transparent
and allow people to learn from this
experience so it never happens again
and that certainly is the challenge
right now for those looking into it
doctor amishadalja thank you